[Music]
check out willow and Jaden Smith
fiercely posing an interview magazine
September issue this is the
brother-sister duo's first cover
together and the pair did not disappoint
the Cree spirited teenagers are totally
twinning in avant-garde ensembles that
are out of this world inside the glossy
Jada and Will Smith's kids sat down with
Pharrell Williams and explained where
the dynamic duo get their unique
perspective from Willow says her mom and
dad are her biggest inspiration quote
what my parents have given to me is not
anything that has to do with money or
success or anything that society says
people should be focusing on it's
something spiritual that only certain
people can grasp and accept and that's
how I act and move in the world today
Jaden shared the same sentiments adding
I 100% agree with willow on that one my
parents are definitely my biggest role
models and that's where me and willow
both pull all of our inspiration from to
change the world
[Music]